le 19 mars dernier le gouvernement
portugais a annoncé un confinement
obligatoire pour les personnes atteintes
du virus dans tout le pays pour 15 jours
quatre jours après son voisin espagnol
les personnes malades contaminés par un
coronavirus ou qui sont sous
surveillance active sur décision des
autorités sanitaires sud saint jean est
hâtive pour ces personnes nous avons
imposé un isolement obligatoire soit à
l'hôpital soit leur domicile et la
violation de cet isolement obligatoire
constituera un acte criminel de
désobéissance et jure le sens de quinze
jours plus tard le pays décide de
prolonger le confinement
comme le reste du monde nous le
confinement est toujours nécessaire
et j'ajouterais même plus que nécessaire
non pas parce que le nombre de nouveaux
cas ne ralentit pas mais parce qu'avec
le temps il augmente depuis ces annonces
le portugal se retrouve déserté les rues
sont vides et le confinement est
respectée depuis son arrivée sur le
territoire la pandémie a fait plus de
200 morts
un chiffre important mais bien loin de
celui de son voisin espagnol qui a passé
la barre symbolique des dix mille morts
alors pourquoi de telles différences
entre deux pays voisins
la première la réactivité du
gouvernement portugais
il a rapidement adopté des mesures pour
freiner la contagion notamment en
portant des masques de chine cet effort
logistique est très important bien qu'il
y ait des tonnes de matériel l'intensité
de la pandémie exige également une
utilisation importante du matériel du
coup la capacité d'utilisation et
d'épuisement des stocks est très rapide
la deuxième raison est d'ordre
géographique
le portugal a la particularité de
n'avoir une frontière terrestre qu'avec
un seul voisin
cela facilite et contrôle des arrivées
des départs sur son territoire enfin le
déroulement du confinement
respecté par les 10 millions de
portugais inspirée par l'exemple donné
par leur président qui s'est mis en
quarantaine dès le 8 mars dernier par
simple précaution moins touché que
l'espagne voisine le portugal ne peut
pour autant crier victoire
le manque d'hôpitaux menace de mener le
pays vers des semaines plus sombres
notamment fin avril période où le pays
pourrait connaître le pic de l'épidémie